on est un organisme de charité on est là
pour donner non pas pour savoir quand
vient le milieu de la philanthropie
regarde avec inquiétude les
développements de la faire une tournée
dans pandémie doré l'effet que vivre
sans train de créer un autre contrecoup
c'est certain que lorsqu'il ya des
interrogations par rapport à un
organiste que ce soit 8 ch réunis en
français salah des effets collatéraux
sur la confiance des donateurs sur
l'ensemble du secteur
mais comment s'assurer de la bonne
gestion des fondations comme unis à
l'aef et nous à ce qu'on fait auprès de
nos membres c'est qu'on fait vraiment la
formation d'une charte des droits du
donateur la la la la première règle
c'est vraiment la transparence ce qui
passe notamment par la publication des
états financiers pour savoir comment
l'argent est dépensé
les membres du conseil d'administration
veilleux normalement à la bonne gestion
des fonds et de l'organisation
dans le cas du nid la vague de
démissions de son ca est un signe du
problème de gouvernance qui avait une
fragilité dans la structure de
gouvernance notamment de cette
organisation à la et c'est ce qui vient
d'être révélée unitas et unique au
canada dans sa structure et même dans
son rôle dans le montage dans son plan
d'affaires globalement c'est ses traits
jurés américains comme façon de faire la
structure c'est l'autre ans jules parce
qu'une y possède une branche commerciale
me to huy qui finance ses activités
un mélange entre nos bnl une entreprise
sociale qui est aussi au coeur du
problème selon cet expert où on essaie
de combiner des objectifs sociaux avec
des objectifs économiques et où on n'a
pas toujours des garde-fous pour
s'assurer que les objectifs sociaux
soient réellement prêts à leur juste
valeur et entreprises sociales c'est une
entreprise privée
donc lorsqu'il ya sept pas si tu es là
c'est la clé
défis de gouvernance mais quelles
pourraient être les conséquences pour
unis il ya des organismes comme on doit
rencontre à revenu canada on peut perdre
mais rod charité donc en perdon numéro
de charité on perd le privilège
d'émettre des reçus pour fins d'impôt
qui est un facteur d'attraction pour les
donatrices et les donateurs en fin de
compte dans cette histoire ce sont les
liens politiques qui retiennent
l'attention
c'est pour cette raison que la
transparence est primordial n'ya pas de
favoritisme
on est tous là pour le bien être des
personnes les plus vulnérables la simple
apparence de conflit d'intérêts pu nuire
à la cause si bienfaisant soit elle
issigeac audrey charbonneau radio canada
mon frère